[Applaudissements]
non l'autre la suite hissbach a levé la
suite avec le pub local le bon tant pis
oui je sais j'ai l'air un peu con à la
même uniforme y est pour beaucoup
parce que ma femme me dit toujours tu as
signé sans réfléchir
le module alors et j'ai demandé aux
autres ils ont fait pareil si la
réparation avait réfléchi à pacy ne faut
pas le prendre pour des cons plus au
mercure en paca table police aille et
examens et tout pas donné suite soit moi
je suis produite voici kiev qui m'a dit
combien je dois tu m'as dit alors il ya
des examens j'ai dit je sais pas 15 me
dit bon signal à 15 ans et du bol j'ai
vu ça au hasard tu aurais pu art ou faux
j'avais toujours et et puis c'est bien
l'uniforme c'est pour dry et des gueuses
h1n1 alors m alors moi je compte passer
un bon à notre exemple alors mettons
alors celui-là
alors je vous le fais eh ben la blonde
des gloss hockey ouais j'avoue papier
chez de la police airware ginette jolie
jeune fille 17 ans wawa aussi de métier
moi oui c'est votre petit frère votre
fils bon circuler non là c'est un
mauvais exemple
mais d'habitude ça marche tout le temps
et didon d'un gosse grande comme ça et
des cheveux longs de france comme ça
bricoler merde
après 18 heures pour les manifs [ __ ]
c'est pas le mieux comprendre un
magnifique s'est farci à 21 heures pour
moi de sortir marquer on a le droit
d'aller voir un nom n'y va pas parce
qu'il fait trop peur qu'on le quitte
alors comme ça il apprend bien pigrée
sortira ses bagages il pourra face tu
veux pour aller poser par terre on ne
connaît pas et tu pourras enfin su il
pourra rentrer dans les annales meury
d'armé terre d'armide les barbus mer de
la marine
le reich pas quoi mais j'aimerais mieux
qu'ils fassent pas polis parce que la
police est trop tard graco métier c'est
vrai c'est ingrat parce que joua pas sûr
parce que jouer à passer sur les passes
je parle parce que les gens nous aiment
pas ces confessions ou là pour les
protéger on est là pour les défendre
j'ai remarqué les gens plus il ya deux
flics autour de plus ils ont peur c'est
flagrant c'est dans les manifs
parce que nous dans les manifs on est
obligé de cogner un faux pas pour le
plaisir
1 il nous oblige non plus on fait gaffe
parce que dans les manifs les fils des
grisons les cheveux longs leur connaît
pas et et puis de données manifs et les
appariteurs ces flics en civil comme un
humaniste par ces ceux qui cassent les
vitrines les campeurs pour les ouvriers
étudiants est déconnez pas se repiquer
et nous ont fait mal fait tu as par le
coup quand à poissy ryan gosling
bref il est une fois sarrio net ap lu
sur ap li qui l'ont dit c'est une bavure
times michael murray
wells a pas cette envie de bavay 1 à
jemappes humains imputables au treuil où
une bande de jeunes ans par mathieu
joyal et j'en ai dit oui à la police et
un refuge pour les alcooliques qu'on a
pas voulu sncf aux ptt
oui mais non c'est exagéré parce que moi
je vois je suis pas un gros commissariat
mais je vois déjà rien contre le miss
arias que je suis est un as au moins que
du spo de bêtises il y en a au moins
quatre qui boivent pas si de la bière
non puis l'apéritif avec les copains du
vin tap
m'enfin basse ainsi comme dans tous les
trucs où ils préparent des brebis
galeuses qui se glissent nouna robert
c'est un grand hilarante
c'est un troupeau à lui tout seul et
l'autre jour il a rigolé jamais je n'ai
eu un il avait arrêté un mec pour état
d'ivresse qui était plus court et que
lui sèchement faut dire que l'autre plat
sa musette
était ce un pâle mais vraiment il
s'appelait un charcutier moustache
beaucoup ressent pas on lui a prévu le
coup et ou à air avait révisé mais ramos
faut parler alors qu'ils étaient
justement je me dépêche de rentrer
précieux vu que dans sa tête je suis on
peut avoir un accident
après ils ont fait un concours le ballon
tu as vu les couloirs des ballons y en
avait ce n'était même pas marqué dans le
manuel serrat verte est devenue non mais
balèze et s'entraîne sur le dieu tient
l'autre jour j'étais deux factions une
intersection affecté à sarrians des
usagers en clair je buvais un carrefour
bon gta depuis un bon quart d'heure je
foutais rien savez comme quand vous rien
de fait
un peu comme lui la vraie bon alors on
foutait rien et puis j'étais là et je
vois un mec qui s'amène avec un petit
papier jeu s'intitule m demande un
renseignement
mona a dit que tu l'osés potes qu'il
avait peur aux gens de meklouche à peu
d'années un art et passion nous nous
apprend à reconnaître et meklouche ont
fait des stages avec les chiens et où
eux sur les celui-là était pas
franchement louche mais était
franchement basané 1
alors moi je l'avais vu le mec mais je
faisais mine que rien tiens je vais vous
le faire je fais bien non mais je
m'entraîne alors j'étais là et le make
it or not
avec son petit papier je sentais que
vous lui osé pas le genre de mec
patibulaire tu vois mais presque bon
alors finalement il s'amène à monsieur
l'agent sur play excusez moi à ce que
c'est que me dit que excusez moi pas sur
la tête
le commissariat de police au complet
excusez moi parce qu'ils et j'en parle
de mettre à pied du docu jeu devrait
faire une déclaration
excusez moi oui vous avez vous pas qu
ils ne savaient pas du long terme le
commissariat
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]